bad news sells and in fact I recently
heard someone basically say that the
only way to get attention to education
is through bad news and that may be part
of the problem we do score our kids do
score less well than some kids in other
countries and that's not new so there's
apparently there's a long-standing and
fairly stable difference in performance
in mathematics between our kids and the
kids and olive developed East Asia Hong
Kong Singapore Japan Korea which wasn't
developed until to recently that's
that's fairly stable what you get when
you compare us to countries that are
more similar to us Australia and New
Zealand England Scotland maybe even
Germany is a little less clear because
the results are not consistent from one
test to another one test puts us pretty
much in the same league as countries
like Australia and Canada want another
test the PISA test run by the OECD in
Paris suggests that our kids are behind
in mathematics I think it's we don't
know because the tests aren't designed
to allow us to sort this out very well
but it appears that it's because the
tests measure different things the tests
that measure what's taught in school put
us higher up relative to those countries
the ones that measure the one that
measures application to more realistic
problems shows us falling a little
further behind
you